hey guys I'm safety I'm Mike I'm Sarah
and today we're gonna be telling awkward
gym class stories gym class wow I
haven't even thought about gym class in
years it was a good social experience
but I mostly just sat down for me it was
something to break up the monotony of
the the studying part it was a great
class for me I really liked moving
around and being active things with
balls that might sound weird I just
really liked playing with ball and class
this is an awkward jokester I haven't
thought about this in a really long time
I must have been 12 maybe 13 nobody
liked this gym teacher everyone had this
ill sentiment towards this guy and I
thought I would you know show up for
everybody it's so we're in the locker
room we're kind of like getting ready to
go back to class and I put up my middle
finger cuz I'm like you know what this
guy dude comes right around the corner
sees me doing it I probably turned beet
red
it gets fuzzy here but he said something
like please do not disrespect me or
something like that I deserved it let's
be honest I was in seventh grade my
period started I was like a late bloomer
from my period so I didn't know when I
would start and when I would finish and
like what it felt like so we did a mile
around after the mile I was done and
like for some of these I was just really
sweaty like everywhere I was like no
this is fine I'll ignore it but after
gym class I went to my history class and
I sat down in my chair and I was still
like sweating and I just kept Fanning
myself like constantly I was like why am
i sweating and I finally cooled down and
the bell rang and I was one of the last
people to get up and I got up and I
looked down it was just a chair and I
saw it and I ran out putting my stuff
and then one lunch was over
I like peeked through the door to see
who was sitting in my chair and it was
probably just sat and like my period
blood and sweat so in gym class we had a
basketball unit in the gym so we would
get changed in the locker rooms and come
outside and I remember this one day
coming out of my locker room my friend
comes up behind me and she was just
talking to me and then all of a sudden
my crush at the time walks out of the
boys locker room and I started walking
towards him and wanting to talk to him I
don't know where my friend pants me from
behind I was clearly wearing a Pikachu
underwear there was a Pikachu on my
underwear my crush saw it he looked at
it he looked at me I'm trying to pull my
shorts up and all he could say was is
that a Pikachu for all of you that are
still in gym class just know that
whatever embarrassing things that you do
now it's gonna be funny in the future it
might suck right now but you'll look
back and you'll laugh at it and that's
the only way you can go about life
[Music]